and metro police are looking for a
gunman who shot two people on The Strip
over the weekend they also told us after
that shooting the person just ran off
tonight 8 news now reporter Victoria
Saha speaking with a woman who shares
how she came inches away from that
shooter
Emily flowers was leaving her job at the
Fashion Show late Saturday night when
suddenly she
ET fire I did
I did hear your screens of pain
terrified herself flowers ran as fast as
she could to her bus stop not knowing
she was about to come face to face with
danger I had somebody literally just
grab my shirt from behind and pulled me
off the bus
and like pulled me to the side and like
pulled me down and I realized then like
I thought was going on he was just like
oh it's standing like really broad tall
trying to make himself wide he was had
the gun putting down like this and was
like uh just like brandishing it like I
said raving it around like crazy yelling
flowers says the gunman wanted the bus
driver to drive off with him but the
driver didn't want to put any of his
passengers in danger he was yelling and
screaming the whole time we just get off
the bus get off the bus we all got down
low in case anything happened the gunman
did get off the bus metro police later
releasing these images they also say two
people were arguing when the shooter
shot at them and ran off as for flowers
the incident has her on edge I'm just
happy to be alive it was insane like I
still have a lot of jitters and
everything
now police say the two men were shot
were taken into hospital if you know
anything about this incident you were
asked to please contact Crime Stoppers
702-385-555 and remember you can remain
online and remain anonymous when you
make that submission